ich finde es ganz merkwürdig wir stehen
vor einer wahl die eben nicht nur die
nächsten vier jahre bestimmt sondern
ökologisch besprochen eben viel viel
weiter reicht als das am nächsten vier
jahren muss ökologisch der
klimapolitisch so viel gemacht werden es
ist nicht 100 wahl vor der wir stehen
und die die parteien die medien hatten
einen sommer lang zeit die menschen
darüber zu informieren was sie auf dem
spiel steht was tatsächlich phase ist in
sachen weltklima wie tief die
katastrophe ist oder in keinem
augenblick in diesem sommer in kaum
einem gespräch und kaum einem format
hatte ich das gefühl irgendwer wagt es
das tatsächlich auf den tisch zu legen
und gerade als dann wirklich alle
organisiert anfängen so ein bisschen
übers klima zu reden stellte man fest
und noch ein paar wochen bis zu wahlen
jetzt können wir über mögliche
koalitionsoptionen
sprechen in jedem gespräch ja alle
gleichzeitig die ganze zeit über uns
eigentlich alles offen halten also ich
glaube es geht auch mit bereitschaft
thematisch zu werden aber ich finde es
komplett gravierend wir sind wenige tage
vor der bundestagswahl wie sie sagen und
irgendwann muss ja meinen menschen dann
die menschen darauf hinweisen und darauf
vorbereiten was jetzt gerade ansteht und
dass diese wahl die die ansteht dass das
nicht in der geschmacksfrage ist das ist
wirklich nicht darum geht wer kommt mit
grad sympathisch wäre eine gute frisur
weißen anzug selbst gut sondern das ist
eine moralische frage ist eine
gewissensfrage
wo geht es hin sind wir bereit alles zu
tun um die großen katastrophen
abzuwenden sind wir bereit tatsächlich
zukunft in die hand zu nehmen sind eher
bereit junge generation zu schützen da
steht auf dem spiel in dieser wahl und
ich frag mich wann das irgendwer
ausspricht sie haben gesagt das ist ja
visionslos der bundestagswahlkampf den
sie erlebt haben
naja es ist ja eigentlich ganz logisch
weil die union und jetzt 16 jahre lang
regiert die groko also die spd auch acht
jahre und wir stehen für einen
ökologischen scherbenhaufen die
emissionen steigen dieses jahr
wahrscheinlich mehr als in den letzten
30 jahren das ist schon ein richtiger
abfahrt muss man mal so sagen so und
jetzt müsste man natürlich als große
koalition aus spd und union sich
hinstellen und sagen sorry leute wir
haben uns komplett verrannt wir haben es
nicht in den griff bekommen wir haben
die krise nicht sehen wollen wir haben
sie weitestgehend kleingeredet werden
sie ignoriert wie an alle möglichen öko
maßnahmen dämonisiert alle kleinen
probleme die auftreten können irgendwie
auf die grünen geschoben er nebenbei
haben wir den zwei featurettes ein
bisschen applaudiert aber auch mehr
nicht und wir haben es einfach nicht
geschafft was zu tun ist und wir haben
es nicht gewagt im video den willen zu
mobilisieren dem man bräuchte das hätte
man machen müssen vor diesem wahlkampf
um dann zu sagen hey ihr wisst ihr was
klimakrise ist da und haben uns
entschieden wie man es anders machen wir
uns angehen wenn aber niemand ist wagt
einmal zu sagen
wir müssen uns hier glaube ich
entschuldigen wir müssen hier mal
ehrlich sprechen dann muss natürlich ein
großer teil des wahlkampfs immer und
immer wieder die ausreden und vor allem
verantwortung sucherei sein also
natürlich muss ununterbrochen das
gespräch über gestern geführt werden wer
hat gestern wohl irgendwelche kohle
kraftwerke nicht abgeschaltet
wer hat damals da irgendwas zu
verantworten gehabt statt aber sich
eigentlich was man jetzt machen müsste
nach vorne zu gehen zu sagen okay leute
die um vier jahre zeit um mehr zu machen
als in jeder legislaturperiode davor wir
müssen mehr die hand nehmen sie die
leute gewöhnen müssen die mehrheit
mobilisieren
aber das geht nicht wenn niemand ehrlich
darüber wird wie sehr man wirklich
verpackt hat ehrlich gesagt wie tief die
krise ist und vor allem auch wie tief
die einen klasse jetzt aber diese frage
dem zusammenhang von neubauten sind sie
nicht am meisten enttäuscht von ihrer
eigenen grünen partei weil diese ganze
wohl fühle rhetorik die kommt doch auch
von ihren eigenen leuten wie gesagt wenn
sie von meiner eigenen leuten sprechen
dann denke ich an die klimabewegung und
wir haben wirklich etwas hat das gegeben
was wir hätten tun können hiess im
wahlkampf ob sie sind doch bei den
grünen naja und helfer was heißt da
stand die grünen machen ja ihre
programme und ihren ich weiß dass also
sie sind mitglied bei den grünen genau
also na ja das ist das ist ja das ist ja
sozusagen der politische arm im
parlament wenn man so will die
fortsetzung von ford is for future auf
der straße im parlament das ist glaube
ich ein verständnis der klimakrise von
2003 oder so also hey das die menschheit
größte krise auf der ganzen welt und wir
haben da eine oppositionspartei und die
kann es für uns klären was für ein
politikverständnis was für ein
demokratieverständnis was für den krisen
verständnis die klimakrise geht jede
partei an und die grünen haben das früh
erkannt als andere das glaube ich wissen
was eigentlich ist nicht mehr in deren
dna aber mittlerweile und gottseidank
erkennen dass sie auch alle
demokratischen parteien ist es
hauptaufgabe
kritische partei pläne und maßnahmen
vorzulegen ziele zu definieren und dann
menschen dafür zu gewinnen und das haben
alle in diesem wahlkampf nicht so
gemacht wie man es machen müssen dass
man sich doch sind sie in dem
zusammenhang am meisten enttäuscht von
ihrer grünen partei
weil dieses vage im wagen bleiben im
ungefähren bleiben das erleben wir doch
von allen parteien bloß keinem wehtun
etwas ganz schön das doch permanent
verströmt wird ist leute es ist schlimm
aber macht euch keine sorgen irgendwie
hat es für euch persönlich keine
weiteren konsequenzen und anstrengend
holt ich bin enttäuscht davon dass zwar
jede demokratische partei meint ist ein
angebracht klimaschutz auf ihre plakate
zu schreiben eines kammer finde es
gerade versprechen zu machen aber keine
demokratische partei dann die maßnahmen
auf den tisch legt die eigentlichen
ausreichen würden also niemand hat einen
plan für 1,5 grad müssen wir feststellen
dass ist gravierend das ist eine
komplette absage an alle menschen die
nur ein vages interesse daran haben
zukünftig auf einem intakten planeten zu
leben klammer auf muss man natürlich
sagen es gibt riesen große diskrepanzen
zwischen den parteien also bei euch
glaube ich sozusagen pro blieb uns gar
nicht mehr schönzureden bei euch schon
eher aber unterm strich ist es natürlich
erst mal ein riesenproblem dass es
keinen plan gibt für 15 grad von keiner
partei das zweite große problem ist
natürlich dass es
dass die partei sich darüber nicht
ehrlich werden und nicht sagen ey leute
die haben die probiert werden aber
keinen bock auf klimaschutz deswegen
wählt uns trotzdem aber macht nicht so
gern damit wenn ihr wirklich klimaschutz
volt und das dritte große probleme und
das ist vielleicht auch eine teil
enttäuschung in diesem wahlkampf die
jetzt sagen gemeinsam geführt wurde ist
dass die wirklichkeit das haben sie
vorhin zitiert die wirklichkeit über die
klimakrise weitgehend verdeckt wurde
wenn man sich aber vor stellt keine
partei hat einen plan für 1,5 grad keine
partei traut sich darüber zu sprechen
wie tief die eingriffe sind die
notwendig sind dann kann es ja auch kein
interesse geben von irgendein
sportteilen ehrlich zu werden ich finde
sein und das ist und das ist in dem
sinne auch logisch ich finde aber auch
die das diw hat letztens eine studie
auch dazu herausgegeben die nochmal
austeigen okay wie groß sind eigentlich
die unterschiede man muss da vorsichtig
sein wenn ich sage keine partei im land
für 1,5 grad dann meine ich dass
einerseits der pauschal aber auf der
anderen das sehen wir wirklich dass es
eklatante unterschiede gibt in der art
und weise wie parteien bereits sind
tatsächlich mal auf den tisch zu legen
kühnert der vorwurf der raum steht sie
versuchen sich das noch schön zu reden
also kaufe ich jetzt nicht persönlich
aber die die feststellung dass ich sie
persönlich ist der vorwurf gegen die spd
ja gut wir sind ja
ja ja aber sehr wohl it also was ich
absolut zugestehe ist wir haben in der
deutschen öffentlichkeit dazu gehören
parteien und dazu gehört insbesondere
eine hochphase der kommunikation wie ein
wahlkampf wir haben keine sprache für
die klimakrise in deutschland ist fehlt
uns an einer übersetzung
in alltags deutsch für das was ein pc
report und andere uns mit auf den weg
geben und das bloße aufzählen ich glaube
das ist die erfahrung die ihr als
bewegung aufgemacht habe das bloße
aufzählen von szenarien wie sie
eintreten können reicht für sich
genommen nicht aus und menschen von der
notwendigkeit zum konkreten handeln
warum hat olaf scholz soll ich gemacht
überzeugen warum hat olaf scholz das
naja gemacht wenn man schon
logisch wenn der urlaubsort ernsthaft
kohlekraftwerke sorry camping gleich
aber ganz ehrlich wenn er ernsthaft
kohlekraftwerke bis 20 38 laufen lassen
möchte und das ist und ich meine das
muss man sich mal vor schluss bedeutete
dass es unmöglich für uns unsere 1,5
grad versprechen einzuhalten ist
unmöglich das zu tun was wir als
deutschland verantworten ist nebenbei
raubt es noch sechs dörfern wo menschen
leben komplett alles was sie haben und
buddelwerth wie so würde man wenn man
das auf der einen seite möchte dann
ehrlich darüber werden wie groß die
klimakrise ist das würde ja bedeuten man
sagt leute sorry wir haben wir diese
menschheits krise wir haben keine
sprache für sie wir haben so etwas noch
nie erlebt wir werden eine ganz andere
art von politik machen müssen klar ich
werde aber erst mal dafür sorgen meiner
politik dass diese krise noch viel
schlimmer wird das ist doch logisch dass
man dann sagt ja wir machen so ein
bisschen klimas das nicht hier und ein
bisschen moderator klimaschutz dar ich
sehe es anders also zunächst mal ist der
plan der spd nicht dass wir eine
punktlandung beim kohleausstieg 20 38
machen sondern in den beschlüssen des
festgehalten spätestens 20 38 wir
wiederholen dass in unserem programm das
kann man kritisieren oder nicht aber
selbstverständlich kann man da früher
raus muss man auch deutlich früher raus
es gibt nur konditionen dafür in unserer
gesellschaft und die sind eben das
vorhandensein von regenerativen energien
in der entsprechenden größenordnung die
notwendig ist und ich glaube die
erfahrung die politische akteurinnen und
akteure in den letzten jahren gemacht
haben gerade in wahlkämpfen wo es
einfach darum geht dann auch für die
eigenen pläne mehrheiten zu kriegen die
erfahrung ist dass die menschen
logischerweise richtigerweise alles was
vorgeschlagen wird mit ihren alltag
abgleichen mit ihren mobilitätsform mit
ihren einkommensfragen das abgleichen
usw es ist vollkommen legitim dass die
bevölkerung diesen praxis check im
alltag macht und wir haben schlechtes
management von klimaschutzmaßnahmen
bisher das bisschen die der die spitze
des eisberges sein klimaschutz maßnahmen
die wir überhaupt nur bisher auf den weg
gebracht haben wir vorsichtiger einstieg
in den co2 preis und ähnliches sind
jetzt schon handwerklich so schlecht
gemacht wegen lobbyinteressen wegen
leuten bei cdu/csu und anderen die dafür
sorgen dass ich gleich es beim 8 naja
nehmen wir doch zum beispiel was mit
entsprechenden vorhin über wohnung ja
jetzt mal was
co2 preis bitte genau co2 preis beim
wohnen zum beispiel das betrifft über 50
prozent der bevölkerung in deutschland
die zur miete leben und viele von den
heizen ihre wohnungen oder häuser auf
grundlage von öl gas und zum gewissen
anteil auch fernwärme seit anfang des
jahres wird auf diese art zu heizen ein
co2 preis erhoben so wie überall sonst
auf 25 euro die tonne das heißt für eine
durchschnittliche 70 quadratmeter
wohnung durchschnittlicher zustand in
deutschland im moment 80 euro bei 1 70
euro bei gas mehrbelastung pro jahr
verdoppelt sich der co2 preis kann man
sich jetzt alles ausrechnen was das
bedeutet die union hat und zwar gegen
die klärte position der spd und der
kanzlerin durchgesetzt dass dieser
komplett co2 preis nur bei der fragen
des heizens bei den mieterinnen und
mietern hängen bleibt die null komma
null einfluss darauf haben ob dieses
heizsystem und damit der energieträger
wir können das machen wir eigentlich nur
die machen jetzt
erfahre ich nach vorne wieder herzlich
angelegenheit sie machen jetzt gerade
wieder ganz platten ball kam doch was
ist denn daran falsch was ich gerade
gesagt dass ich nichts falsch aber vater
wahlkampf wir reden wir reden über über
versicherungs weise warum sehen sie
wenn sie den horizont erscheint damit
gerühmt hat dass der co2 preis so
niedrig ist am anfang als man diesen
wahnsinn vorschlag von zehn euro um die
ecke kam dass er effektiv also komplett
wirkungslos war also eigentlich eine
lächerlichkeit und ne also ich weiß
nicht so ne verarschung von jeder person
die das gefühl hatte die regierung als
verstanden und das ist ja sagen wo wir
stehen das ist das wesentliche und
möglichkeiten sind ja im moment nicht da
und ich verstehe die überlegung dass ich
eure mit denen ihr einsteigen wollte das
wurde einfach mal bei der ihm leben
genommen indem mit dem haus liegt bei
180 euro einzusteigen wir auch nicht
aber die sache ist doch die er nicht
verstehe dass die lern als
entschuldigung das ist jetzt auch ein
bisschen post faktisch ehrlich denn acht
jahre lang diese große hatten diesmal
aus post faktisch wenn man diese acht
jahre lang dieser politik der union aber
auch als goya mitträgt und alles und ich
meine das sagen das ist liebe
naturschutzgesetz durchgesetzt luisa
entschuldigung dass mich kurz an
sprechen 40 jahre lang mit regen leben
weil ich es steht heute davor dass die
eu deutschland verklagt wegen
klimazielen wegen schlechter luft die
wälder sterben die emissionen steigen
wie wir kommen nicht aus der kohle zu
treffen berg die erneuerbaren sind
praktisch komplett eingebrochen es ist
jetzt sagen dass die reben selbst
gemacht also klimaschutz ist ja nicht
sagen nicht nur schlecht gewesen sondern
wir können eigentlich davon zu sprechen
dass inmitten einer riesengroßen
ökologischen eskalation auf so eine art
stillstands niveau navigiert wurde
und in keinem augenblick in diesen acht
jahren grob ihr gesagt liebe union das
mit dem klima das ist ein thema das ist
so wichtig und wenn ihr nicht mitmacht
dann steigen wir daraus kein einziges
mal habt ihr irgendwie die eine hose gab
zu sagen und es ist so wichtig hier sind
bereit wirklich welche konsequenzen
ziehen die entschuldung der ist
klimaschutz und das klimaschutz
einsetzen sie hatten das
klimaschutzgesetz mit sektor erzielen
was wir jetzt haben was nicht ausreicht
und das am anfang schlecht an das
verfassungsgesetz kommen der musik jetzt
müssen wir differenzieren zwischen
einstieg in maßnahmen mit dem was reicht
reicht das nein haben wir das erste mal
ein klimaschutzgesetz mit sektor ziel
sind ministerien wie das von andy
scheuer verpflichtet wenn sie ihre
jährlichen einsparziele nicht einhalten
darzulegen wie sie binnen kürzester
frist gedenken das nachzuholen ja wer
hat das durchgesetzt die spd in den
koalitionsverhandlungen
müssen bitte fair bleiben bei dem
argument kommt mir vielleicht können wir
einmal zeigen mal ganz kurz wie olaf
scholz vizekanzler und finanzminister
wie der damals reagiert hat als dieses
urteil vom bundesverfassungsgericht kam
es wurde mit folgenden worten
kommentiert wir haben mal ganz kurz rein
das großartige an diesen ich kann das
gar nicht sagen anders seinem coolen
spruch des bundesverfassungsgerichts ist
das ist eigentlich übersetzt folgendes
gesagt hat ziele haben ist ja schön
sagen wie es geht ist noch viel besser
so das coole urteil des
verfassungsgerichts
also die hauen denen die dafür
verantwortlich sind ihre eigene politik
um die ohren und man stellt sich hin und
sagt danke für dieses coole urteil muss
ihnen jetzt aber nicht ernsthaft
mehrheitsbildung in der demokratie
zwischen koalitionspartnern erklären
oder weil so was hat das damit zu tun
hat dass gesetze die paten die koalition
auf den weg bringen nicht der
idealvorstellung jedes einzelnen
koalitionspartners ok 1019 wurde wurde
das klimapaket verhandelt
zwei leute
wenn das stimmt was robin alexander in
seinem buch der machtverfall schreibt
auf seite 1 114 es gab zwei leute die
sich ganz entschieden dafür
ausgesprochen haben den co2 preis so
weit wie möglich unten zu halten gegen
den erklärten willen der kanzlerin wer
war das
wenn es jetzt gleich vortragen aber sie
verengt gerade die diskussion auf einmal
olaf scholz ja und was sie verlängere
das richtige waren eben gerade beim
urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichtes
was ja was ganz anderes dem gegenstand
hat als die ausgestaltung der frage des
co2 politik
das gericht um glaubwürdig nach es geht
um den gesamten kontext es geht doch um
glaubwürdigkeit
wir können hier nicht immer hin und her
springt zwischen der einzelnen maßnahmen
und dem großen kontext politik ist ein
komplexes gebilde und hat die klimakrise
in ihrer gesamtheit zu betrachten und
auch also ich kenne niemanden und lehrer
oder der noland erklären möchte dass der
co2 preis der einzige und entscheidende
schlüssel für die frage des konsequenzen
entscheiden der wichtiger teil ja aber
ich habe doch vorhin versucht
darzustellen wir haben jetzt ein
einstieg mit diesem instrument gemacht
und während des einstieges machen ganz
viele menschen ganz konkret in ihrem
alltag die erfahrung dass das was
behauptet wird nämlich das ja eine
längliche wirkung das ist doch alles was
ich mache und ich leide dabei sprechen
aber erleichterungen gewöhnlichkeit es
berührt den kern dessen was immer es
auch war gleich verstehe ich reicht
nicht den leuten aufzumalen was
passieren wird so absehbar ist sein mag
wir sind in einer demokratie klimaschutz
mussten demokratie fest am ende sein das
darf nicht so viele leute nein die leute
müssen über einen weg von 20 25 jahren
bereits ein mitzugehen und wir wissen
alle was menschen in dieser gesellschaft
für kriterien anlegen wenn sie sagen
okay dann sie verstehen doch ganz genau
da kommt man nicht so einfach ist es
doch es ist doch ein punkt zu sagen uns
geht es als spd an der in dem punkt um
die soziale frage wir wollen dafür
sorgen dass autofahren und viele andere
dinge nicht zu teuer wird das kann man
das macht nein das ist eine haltung die
man haben kann ich soll mir einer der
momente selber vortragen und nicht von
ihm vorgetragen sehen und das sind auch
nicht die argumente von olaf scholz wenn
der talanx bitte wenn der co2 preis eine
lenkungswirkung haben soll und dann wird
er eingeführt und all das was er lenken
soll steht als alternativen der form
noch gar nicht da das e auto ist noch
nicht bezahlbar für leute in dem segment
gerade bei denjenigen mit
durchschnittseinkommen die in der region
gebrauchtwagen kaufen wie es notwendig
wäre um umzusteigen es gibt mieterinnen
und mieter die heizen mit öl und gas und
haben nicht die möglichkeit selber
umzustellen es gibt keine politische
einigung darauf dass ist die
vermieterseite tragen soll dann sind das
keine rahmenbedingungen wo die erhöhung
des co2 preis dann auf jetzt hat man 25
gesagt oder 40 oder 60 einen unterschied
im verhalten der menschen getan hätte
das einzige was passiert wäre bei einem
noch höheren einstieg ist dass noch mehr
leute aufstampfen und sagen die erzählen
ja was von sozial gerechten klimaschutz
aber es passiert am ende nicht die
rahmenbedingungen dafür ständig weil die
politischen mehrheiten die haben wir
noch reichlich den leuten jeden sozialen
gerechten klima merklich ruhiger
neubauer der eindruck der dann aber
wenig später erweckt wird ist ich olaf
scholz der oberste klimaschützer stehe
hier und feiere mit dem wort cool dieses
urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichts das
ist mein punkt vielleicht so sagen einen
schritt zurückgehen
das ist wirklich deprimierend also die
klimapolitik der groko war so schlecht
dass das verfassungsgericht gesagt hat
das geht doch nicht dann hat man gesagt
er danke danke wir haben gerne gegen
euch verloren und klimagesetz auf den
weg gebracht das wieder so schlecht war
wieder nicht mit dem 10 von paris
kompatibel war so das finde ich ist
sozusagen erstmal eine interessante
tatsache dass ich jetzt ja die gogo
inszeniert als diejenigen die
klimaschutz machen sondern man muss
nicht wirklich fragen also man muss
wirklich hoffen dass die menschen ist
nicht allen leuten euch abnehmen weil
alles was wir aus den letzten acht
jahren wissen ist er nicht so gut kann
also ich würde
zu ende und dann hab ich zweite sache
und das ist ja so abgefahren in der
klimafrage du hast eben gesagt wir
kommen politik ich würde sagen kann wir
kommen in der klimakrise es geht nicht
darum einfach ein bisschen mehr zu
machen es geht nicht darum was auf den
weg zu bringen und dann zu gucken wie
kommt man dabei raus bei der klimakrise
wenn wir das irgendwie aufhalten müssen
müssen wir genug machen es reicht ja
schon jetzt wir brauchen wir heute hier
sind eine demokratie
ist die debatte zu sagen global einfach
ein budget an die mission es begrenzt
das können wir noch ausstoßen wir müssen
uns daran halten man es bisher sc
nominal daran gescheitert in irgendeiner
weise sich daran zu orientieren obwohl
das konzept budget kennt man ja nicht
aus dem finanzhaushalte wir haben
urlaubstag endlich sehr gut damit aus
man würde denken das ist jetzt nicht
ganz neu aber wenn sich keine parteien
schließt euch so dermaßen ich find's
ganz schön ist es gerade so gut
exemplarisch gezeigt wenn sich keine
partei hinstellt und sagt leute das ist
übrigens die krise die wir haben das
einen neue politische herausforderung
wir werden eine neue art der politik
machen müssen und wenn wir nicht handeln
wird unbezahlbar werden wir die fluten
von nrw noch irgendwie als schöne
erinnerung von anfang märz waren es 20
jahren errungen haben wenn wir nicht
handeln dann kriegt ihr uns ja sonst was
gewinnen oder mehr hast du denn dass
niemand macht es ist doch überhaupt
nicht überraschend dass menschen keinen
bock darauf hin dass mehrere gegen
neuwahlen airlines im moment zu sehen
dass man braucht jedoch ist
unrealistisch betrachten diese
mehrheiten brauchen sie doch um das dann
tatsächlich auch ein politikum ist
dass wir ein klima die position dass man
kurz zu ende ist argument zu ändern
sicher wissen sowie die debatte gerade
geführt wird wie man die klimakrise
runter bürokratisiert und so kleine
stifte projekte die man machen kann oder
nicht ist es ganz logisch dass menschen
mehr angst vor der erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale als vor erhöhung des
meeresspiegels haben aber das
reflektiert in keiner weise die krise in
der wir sind das heißt wenn man nicht
und deswegen sprechen davon dass man
wahrheit erzählen muss dass man die
wirklichkeit in diskussion reinholen
muss der mensch über die wirklichkeit
spricht ja es ist völlig abwegig dass
menschen bereit wären für die maßnahmen
die kommen müssen das geht ja nur wenn
sie wissen was ich das mist wir haben
nicht mehr die wahl zwischen mehr oder
weniger klimaschutz mehr oder weniger
pendlerpauschale mehr oder weniger
kohlekraft wir haben die wahl zwischen
richtig guten schnellen radikalen
klimaschutz oder einer klimakrise wir
sie uns nicht vorstellen wollen und das
sehen wir wie das in ansätzen aussehen
könnten wir schon heute auf vielen
teilen der welt das heißt ein
wirklichkeit befreiter wahlkampf für
diesen damals war wird natürlich nicht
menschen dafür vorbereiten könnt dafür
das was eigentlich notwendig ist und das
müssen sich medien parteien jetzt
anhören und dann würde ich sagen gut lag
bei nächsten legislaturperiode muss ja
trotzdem gehandelt werden und es ist
ganz unklar gerade wieder das eigentlich
angegangen werden